you ever heard of you done whippets no
yeah me neither like my homeboy he was
like dogs like the [__] craziest 15
seconds ever I'm like what 15 seconds
[__] yeah when I interviewed Ghana he
was whippeted out are you [__] me he
walked into the studio with like a
little [__] like box of [__]
and he was just lighting up the whippets
right before he went on camera yeah
Draco loves the whippets too I had I had
a whip whip it infused Draco the ruler
interview oh that's hard by the time he
stood up it was just canisters like all
around him
rest in peace yeah the weapons are
serious but you have a [__] brain
aneurysm and die off you like uh you
like yeah I've never done cocaine one
time I remember I was gonna say this
earlier because it made me think of it
when you were talking about throwing up
on the drugs I think it's the only drug
I've ever thrown up on I don't drink
like that right so
um and we were fishing and we had just
got back from fishing and we were
walking from the pond to my grandpa
house cocaine and fish yeah best ever
love it and uh and uh I'm on the way
back and do this like 8 P.M right and I
uh hit a [__] mean in line dog
and I'm like
feel I was like I don't feel
and I was like nah I pushed that hood
back down and as soon as we get to my
grandpa's I had to see him on the porch
he's like what's up and you know he said
something I just [__] let it all out
boom pooped I puked all over the trailer
this was in a trailer yeah at my
grandpa's double what uh no I don't
think he's a double bed
I've looked in the trailer before yeah
yeah ain't nothing wrong with trailers
[__] shout out to the trailers baby yeah
shout out to the trailers for real some
of them trailers is nice bro especially
don't double wides too you wouldn't even
know it bro on a cool dog I'm cool with
that like I'm happy if God give me that
I'm happy dog like I just need like two
acres in a [__] double way double
wide Academy what a fight with a
firehouse no [__] satellite on top
yeah I don't need no crazy [__] I don't
need no pool I don't need no none of
that you have an inflatable pool yeah
that's even better I do that with a
trampoline you know what I'm saying and
I'm cool with that you get on a
trampoline hell yeah yo this tooth is
fake because when I was a kid I was at
some bitch's house when I was 14 yeah
and we're all jumping on the trampoline
at the same time and I flew so [__]
high in the sky dude I [__] ate [__]
on the concrete [__] my tooth I look
like [__]
like a shittier white version of Nas as
a child
hey shout out my boy Caleb man I need
three more one time it was me him my dog
Pat and Eduardo and I'm talking to my
dog Caleb and he's like talking to make
conversation just stops and just
and just Falls forward right boom and I
I don't know why I should have caught
them but like I did wait what this is on
a trampoline or no it's like on ground
no on dab actually yeah oh yeah dab will
[__] you up so listen dog he just Falls
forward and like I kind of felt like a
hoe cause like I should have caught him
but I thought he was being funny so I'm
like [__] he busted his tooth
straight forward face first on a metal
bucket dog I look at the bucket and the
bucket look like it won but it was still
you know what I'm saying like in like it
was beat in and and then like bro he's
face first like like face down on the
ground like on his belly hands back like
this and we flip him over and we're like
dog Caleb are you good are you gay are
you okay dog what the [__] he was like
yeah I'm okay what are you talking about
you should see yourself yeah dog he
didn't even realize bro like he just
laid there and then he goes
I think my [__] fit uh my tooth is
gone yeah and like he's so non-slumb
about everything dog and I'm sitting
here looking for his tooth look in the
bucket the tooth is in the bucket I'm
like yo
Jesus yeah so he's got a two like that
too and he's like a sick ass night dog
it was scary honestly like in the moment
it was like what the [__] you know I'm
saying everyone's High your boy's
bleeding bro his flat yeah failed Face
First you say uh you had a a puking
experience on cocaine is it true if you
try to have sex on cocaine that you're
you're Johnson will not be up to par
yeah like dope dick
that's a thing yeah I don't know I ain't
never I don't think I've ever
I don't think I've ever tried to [__] on
cocaine because every time I was on
cocaine I was doing some bad [__] right
or just not with women like I'll just
not or I might have been with him just
not worried we've never liked because
I'll be so hyped off this I've never
done Coke off a chick's ass
I feel like that see I've never done
cocaine but I had a girl sniff coconut I
ain't gonna lie bro that [__] sound cool
right but
that whole ass probably just you know
what I'm saying like well there's like
uh the opening scene of snowfall season
one episode one I saw it off uh wolf on
Wall Street or the the dudes
coking this bitch's ass
I never seen that I put x on a [__] ass
though I put X on [__] [__] you put
ecstasy in the bitch's ass
little XO what is EXO yeah okay okay
yeah your taxes slaves you know hey man
they're not called exos I don't know
that was good to see
like the little pills they come they
look like they look like they look like
look Ferraris
yeah did you [__] the pill into her butt
no hell no I'm not an animal
could you imagine if you [__] her
after and then you're getting like
ecstasy like residue up your tickle
Jesus Christ
white powdered [__] that might be kind
of wild yeah that's some wild [__] yeah
you're nasty you're the one stuffing
pills up [__] asses I didn't say [__]
it though I mean
like maybe Lee you could leave the
finger in there yeah you gotta make sure
it gets in there definitely without a
doubt make sure to get in there how was
the uh session after that bro like she
got something to prove hmm
sucking dick look like she sneezed on it
yeah
if it doesn't look like you sneezed on
it I don't want it I don't want it I do
not want it I heard this girl say this
[__] oh there's this video of this girl
on Instagram right and you just see this
dude's legs in the air and it's his feet
right and then she come and you hear
dicks up and then she comes on she's
like if you wanna suck a dick like that
I don't hear y'all you ain't sucking
dick you ain't sucking dick his ass too
bro she was doing she was eating ass she
was going crazy she was get yeah she was
if your legs were up in the air then you
see homeboys legs in the air and he's
like ah
there was a lot more going on than dick
sucking right there dog it said you not
that's on Instagram bro that was on
Instagram